>> Mike: THE U.S. COURT OF
APPEALS HAS ISSUED AN
ADMINISTRATIVE STAY ON DON
MCGAHN, IT WILL ISSUE A LONGER
STAY AND SET ORAL ARGUMENTS FOR
A HEARING JANUARY 3RD, A FEDERAL
JUDGE RULED MONDAY AT BEGAN
WOULD HAVE TO APPEAR BEFORE
CONGRESS REJECTING THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION'S ARGUMENT THAT
ABSOLUTE IMMUNITY SHIELDED TOP A
ABSOLUTE IMMUNITY SHIELDED TOP D
ABSOLUTE IMMUNITY SHIELDED TOP S
ABSOLUTE IMMUNITY SHIELDED TOP F
ABSOLUTE IMMUNITY SHIELDED TOP R
ABSOLUTE IMMUNITY SHIELDED TOP C
ABSOLUTE IMMUNITY SHIELDED TOP N
ABSOLUTE IMMUNITY SHIELDED TOP R
ABSOLUTE IMMUNITY SHIELDED TOP S
ABSOLUTE IMMUNITY SHIELDED TOP I
ABSOLUTE IMMUNITY SHIELDED TOP N
ABSOLUTE IMMUNITY SHIELDED TOP L
QUESTIONING.
CONGRESSIONAL LAWMAKERS ARE BACK
HOME FOR THE HOLIDAYS WHEN THEY
RETURN TO WASHINGTON LAST WEEK,
IMPEACHMENT WILL BE THE BIG
ISSUE.
LET'S GET SOME PERSPECTIVE ON
THAT TONIGHT, BRET BAIER SPOKE
WITH WEST VIRGINIA REPUBLICAN
SENATOR SHELLEY MOORE CAPITO
EARLIER THIS WEEK.
>> Bret: THANK FOR BEING HERE.
OBVIOUSLY THE FOCUS IN
WASHINGTON WILL BE IMPEACHMENT
AND IT SEEMS LIKE IT'S HEADING
TOWARDS YOUR SIDE OF THE CAPITAL
WITH YOU AS A JUROR.
AS YOU SIT HERE TONIGHT HAVING
WATCHED WHAT YOU'VE WATCHED, HOW
DO YOU SEE THIS?
>> I SEE IT AS A POLITICAL BLUNT
INSTRUMENT THAT IT HAS BEEN
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE PROCESS.
WHEN THE HEARINGS WERE PRIVATE,
IT WAS PRETTY OBVIOUS THAT THE
DEMOCRATS WERE USING THIS AS A
WAY TO BE DESTRUCTIVE TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP HIMSELF AND THEN
WHEN IT COMES INTO THE PUBLIC
ARENA OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
WEEKS, I THINK IT SHOWED ITSELF
AGAIN TO BE A VERY DIVISIVE,
VERY PARTISAN EXERCISE AND
DISCOURAGING TO THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC, BUT IT WILL BE COMING
OVER PROBABLY TO THE SENATE, I
WILL BE A JUROR, I'M ALL EARS OF
COURSE TO TRY TO FIGURE THAT OUT
ONCE IT COMES ONTO MY PLATE.
>> Bret: TO THAT POINT, ONE OF
THE PEOPLE MAKING THE CASE IS
THE HOUSE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE
CHAIR ADAM SCHIFF, HERE IS HIS
CLOSING ARGUMENT.
>> WHEN THE FOUNDERS PROVIDED A
MECHANISM IN THE CONSTITUTION
FOR IMPEACHMENT, THEY WERE
WORRIED ABOUT WHAT MIGHT HAPPEN
IF SOMEONE UNETHICAL TOOK THE
HIGHEST OFFICE IN THE LAND AND
USED IT FOR THEIR PERSONAL GAIN.
IN MY VIEW THERE IS NOTHING MORE
DANGEROUS THAN AN UNETHICAL
PRESIDENT WHO BELIEVES THEY ARE
ABOVE THE LAW.
>> Bret: THERE ARE SOME
REPUBLICANS, WILL HURD FROM
TEXAS, OTHERS WHO SAID THAT WHAT
THE PRESIDENT DID AND HOW HE DID
IT WAS INAPPROPRIATE BUT NOT
IMPEACHABLE.
ARE YOU IN THAT CAMP?
>> I THINK PROBABLY HIS
INQUIRIES CAN BE CONSTRUED AS
SUCH BUT ALL THE EVIDENCE HAD
BEEN SECOND AND THIRD HEAD
EVIDENCE.
I'LL TAKE WHAT ADAM SCHIFF IN
HIS OWN WORDS AND THE
SERIOUSNESS WITH WHICH HE SAID
IT, I THINK HE PROTESTS TOO MUCH
IN HIS CLOSING STATEMENT BECAUSE
HE KNOWS THE FACTS ARE NOT
THERE, THE PRESIDENT HAS NOT
BEEN ABLE TO DEFEND HIMSELF AND
SO THE PROCESS HAS BEEN VERY
MUCH NOT WHAT OUR FOUNDERS
WANTED AND OUR RULE OF LAW IS
FOUNDED ON BUT IS BEING USED AS
A DIVISIVE PARTISAN EXERCISE AND
IT'S NOT DOING JUSTICE TO OUR
SYSTEM.
>> Mike: WOW >> Bret: THE
"WASHINGTON EXAMINER" THIS WEEK
HAD THIS IN AN OPINION PIECE
SAYING "REPUBLICANS SHOULD ADMIT
TRUMPS DEMANDS ON UKRAINE WERE
IMPROPER, IF THEY ARE REASONABLY
ENOUGH UNCONVINCED THAT
IMPEACHMENT IS THE RESIN
IMPEACHMENT IS THE REMIN
IMPEACHMENT IS THE REMEDY, THEY
SHOULD TAKE OTHER ACTIONS TO
STEER HIM TOWARD NATIONAL
INTERESTS.
IS CENSURE SOMETHING YOU THINK
THE SET IS GOING TO LOOK AT?
>> YOU CAN SEE THE DRUMBEAT
BEGINNING TO DEVELOP IN THE
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES,
SEVERAL MEMBERS OR AT LEAST ONE
MEMBER HAS MENTIONED THAT
ALREADY.
I THINK IT'S GOING TO BE
PREDICATED ON WHAT THE HOUSE
BRINGS OVER TO THE SENATE AND
WHAT IS LAID ON THE SENSE PLATE
IN TERMS OF THE ARTICLES OF
IMPEACHMENT.
I THINK IF YOU LOOK AT THE WHOLE
TRANSCRIPT OF THE PHONE CALL
WITHIN A FEW MINUTES OR SO THAT
THE PRESIDENT MADE A STATEMENT
ABOUT INVESTIGATING CORRUPTION
AND MENTIONING AN OPPONENT,
MAYBE THAT WASN'T THE EXACT
PROPER WAY -- BUT THE CORRUPTION
ISSUE IS STILL A VERY VIABLE
ISSUE IN UKRAINE AND SOMETHING
THAT WE KNOW THAT IF WE JUST
FUND COUNTRIES WITHOUT WHERE THE
MONEY IS GOING TO GO, WITHOUT
LOOKING AT CORRUPTION, WE ARE
GOING TO GET WHAT WE DESERVE
BACK WHICH IS NOT SATISFACTION.
>> Bret: IF YOU LOOK AT THE
LATEST POLL, IT SAID SHOULD
TRUMP BE REMOVED AND IMPEACHED
FROM OFFICE, IT'S UPSIDE DOWN
NOW, 48 NO, 45 YES.
THAT IS FLIPPED FROM OCTOBER, IF
YOU TOOK A POLL IN
WEST VIRGINIA, WHERE WOULD IT
BE?
>> IF WE TOOK A POLL IN
WEST VIRGINIA IT WOULD BE 65%
NO.
IT WOULD BE 100%, WHY DON'T YOU
DO THE JOB YOU'RE SENT TO DO
WHICH IS TO FUND THE GOVERNMENT,
SUPPORT THE MILITARY, AND MOVE
FORWARD ON REALLY IMPORTANT
ISSUES OF THE DAY?
>> Bret: YOU THINK THIS
PROCESS SO FAR HAS ALREADY
IMPEDED BIG LEGISLATIVE EFFORTS?
>> WE HAVEN'T GOTTEN THE
NATIONAL DEFENSE AUTHORIZATION
PAST, WE HAVEN'T PASSED USMCA,
THE TRADE PACKAGE WITH OUR
NEIGHBORS MEXICO AND CANADA
WHICH WE KNOW WOULD BE VERY
USEFUL TO MY STATE.
I CAN'T FIGURE OUT WHY THAT
HASN'T COME FORWARD EXCEPT THE
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES DOESN'T
WANT TO GIVE THE PRESIDENT OF
WIN GOING INTO THE ELECTION.
WE HAVE AN ELECTION IN NOVEMBER,
THAT'S WHAT ELECTIONS ARE FOR.
>> Bret: YOU ARE JUST ON A
CONGRESSIONAL DELEGATION
OVERSEAS AND HE WENT TO
AFGHANISTAN.
SPEAKING OF THE U.S. MILITARY,
WE HAVE BEEN THERE ON THE GROUND
FOR A LONG TIME.
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT AND THE
EFFORT TO GET U.S. TROOPS BACK
HOME.
>> WE HAVE 14,000 TROOPS THERE
RIGHT NOW, IT WAS NOT LOST ON ME
THAT THE AREAS THAT WE ARE
WORKING ON IN TERMS OF
COUNTERTERRORISM WHETHER IT'S
THE TELE- BAN OR ISIS OR
AL QAEDA ARE EXCEEDINGLY
IMPORTANT, WE HELPED THE AFGHAN
NATIONAL FORCES AND THE NATIONAL
POLICE AND THE GOVERNMENT OF
AFGHANISTAN TO SECURE MORE AND
MORE OF THEIR TERRITORY BECAUSE
IF WE DON'T AND IF WE DON'T WORK
IN THAT TRAIN, ADVISE, AND
ASSIST CAPACITY THAT WE HAVE
BEEN HELPING THEM WITH, THEY ARE
GOING TO BE OVERTAKEN AGAIN BY
VERY VIOLENT TERRORIST GROUPS
WHICH THEN ENDANGERS OUR
HOMELAND, IT'S ABOUT WHAT IS
GOOD FOR OUR OWN SECURITY AND IT
HAS BEEN LONG AND HARD AND
COSTLY IN A LOT OF LIVES AND
TREASURE, I THINK IN THE END,
KEEPING TO HELP SUPPORT THE
MORALE OF THE TROOPS IS GREAT,
I'M SO PROUD OF THEM WHEN I GET
TO SEE THEM.
>> Bret: FOR THE PEOPLE WHO
SAY "19 PLUS YEARS WE HAVE DONE
OUR DUTY THERE.
>> I UNDERSTAND THAT, THERE ARE
TIMES WHEN I FEEL THAT WAY
MYSELF.
I THINK WE CAN DO A LOT MORE
WITH A LOT LESS AND PUT A LOT
LESS LIVES IN DANGER IF WE
FOLLOW THE COURSE THAT WE HAVE
PUT FORWARD.
WE ARE PLANNING TO DRAW DOWN,
THAT IS OBVIOUS.
THE MILITARY LEADERS ALONG WITH
OUR NATO PARTNERS FEEL THAT IS
VERY MUCH IN ORDER.
THE AFGHANISTAN GOVERNMENT, WE
HAVE TO STRENGTHEN THAT, THAT IS
A WEAK POINT RIGHT NOW BECAUSE
THEY HAD AN ELECTION THAT IS
UNDER QUESTION.
I THINK AS FRUSTRATING AS IT IS
AND DIFFICULT AS IT IS FOR THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC, WE GOT TO LOOK
AT OUR HOMELAND SECURITY AND TO
STABILIZE THAT REGION OF THE